they're here if you're filling it's off
the Leonard defended by Simmons is this
[Applause]
fifteen fourth-quarter points by Kawhi
Leonard and the game-winner 41 points
[Applause]
watch Kevin Durant is if the milky way
to for everybody to try to find their
own men third three bound nine boards
for Leonard around their seats my
Raptors have blown this one open on the
defensive end
looks wah why not select it again
another steal - amar it's ktvl
Canada
[Applause]
two veterans know how to make the play
work things I ran off the good defense
[Music]
Donnell said I'll give it up to old and
can roll to get the switch he says
enough
Wow slam you kidding me boom the
two-for-one situation potentially Durant
goes around the world and punches in
home over Ivanka this former OKC
teammate
[Applause]
lizards
[Applause]
eight here the wine let it play in a
city game it coming
you don't need a three but you need a
store rats hammering
I've been Durant dropped one on Newark
it's his head Billy hasn't gotten on
track 16 20 in this game Crowder has
it's a call by 30 then the left this is
spectacular contact all the way and
somehow able to stretch and get that
ball and clean without using the glass
wow that's impressive
[Applause]
face to face is a little more emotion
and I saw he was fed up at the beginning
of the game maybe taking a couple of
plays he doesn't usually get the point
like that trying to loosen up but this
starts with the defense and with
emotional games like this if you're in
the playoffs you you have a bigger goal
it's of team win but tonight when it's
does she get read and reacted they take
the super plays a lot of time
[Applause]
let's see take it to another gear right
there gets around the corner and sends a
message when either they yelled upstart
nuggets yeah we took off I thought he
laid that thing in now I'm using it here
Lowrey to Kauai
seven 125 so coming up and up over using
a glass getting that ball up high tough
angle right there Maddie that commercial
break change the right shoot so valleys
where two separate shoes Oh
throws it down
on exclamation point put the defense at
an emphatic
yeah he's gonna make something happen
but also here he goes right by the guy
yet there it is
whistle
catches he gets it he gets the foul it
gets hit hard but he plays the glass and
he'd been shooting really well late in
the season and forty-nine percent the
first round
Durant to the basket stuff against
harmless played two-man game here
Lillard gets switched on to him Pillai
for the win no timeout no time now
that's the ballgame
[Applause]
how do you like them now looks like they
got right there that hit the rim let's
count it one two three four time
warriors plus eight on the boards Durant
gets a running start and side
Leonard peaks of the clock five shots
what it makes us move we got 13 and 10
with three assists and one emphatic
finish up over the top of a Sixers team
right now that is trying to survive on
the road they outscore the 76ers 37 to
17 and another Kauai light Wizards
scored five straight points to force a
[Music]
one of the toughest matchups in the NBA
and Jeff Green and Kevin Durant
certainly know each other so well from
that 76ers good this game loves the big
stage and he's been a highlight machine
in the postseason the latest one from
Leonard
defending this home for directions
the Warriors open it up with their
largest lead and Kevin Durant's coming
right here living room Paris two thumbs
on the perimeter
[Applause]
recognize the buzzer
[Music]
he's calm
[Applause]
to try to do this
just greeting you today and that had to
get enough time to recover it from album
of a slide at the shot clock at one
KD able to dunk it with the left hand
[Applause]
the soul will suffice
by letter beautiful pass by Gasol the
left hand Matthews Rick Carlisle does
that pretty relentlessly Koran block the
3kd with the steal and a free ride to
slam at home Red's two-way plays block
of three and never have it more easy on
the other end
[Music]
[Applause]
TMT is being presented by Kumho pixel
still by flowey and the exclamation
point here and Drake the reaction rant
took a lot of contact and spotted oh
this might be on Matthews way out front
here seven footer skins finished like
this well Durant can dribble the koji
guards Leonard Leonard backing in clock
down to two top shot and he makes it a
few more minutes pass knocked away push
ahead to Durant's we went to throw it
back to Jordan Bell it ricochets around
and direct out the dog when he was
fouled
oh and he hit the floor very hard and
then this one looked like it was
turnover all the way but careened off
the heels Leonard just two free throw
attempts
lockdown good 31 but we've passed away
with the bucket
obviously team Yanis have the thigh was
it back out sixes have taken 25 priests
and I wrapped his own 16 they've been
able to do this
singer crossover is in a basket Lenalee
shot clock at seven he sizes up
Henderson Lars
kV is three to shoot baseline jumper
grimmy
you couldn't play better defense than
Harrison Barnes right there serge ibaka
gives it back over to Kyle a bucket the
line clock down Leonard escapes trouble
steps into it and connects it's calm a
cool move right here a good movement
watch Leonard he's gonna lift the D and
despite that Davis still almost gets
there they win an oxidant
[Applause]
man tries there and finishes Leonard
working against brown cross the foul in
one Kauai inside a three but the light
takes the pump and finishes but my
cologne furious thought there should
have been a foul call I thought that was
a good no call direct comes right back
no Spurs two-time Defensive Player of
the Year and impressive in his first
year with the Raptors another and one
for Kauai it's also his handle so much
tighter and then the raw power
nationally internationally Bob Jim
Carrey's Burke with you at Oracle sounds
keeping the Warriors all
and the Clippers here at home we head to
the minute mark Kauai the Power Move
Matt that's a good high percentage shot
on the back end of the shot clock two
seconds left
Durant's got the seal dream on the early
seal by KD that's breakpoints the
Warriors do and they've got a lead of
six as a break saw the mismatch went
right to it
back in 2014 he was injured his rookie
year
lead pass Pascal to the cutting Lowery
Lowery behind the back collide when a
slam dunk and starting shot clock down
to five baby on the tape rolling it over
Channel
[Applause]
lockdown Kauai on Jorge backing in 13
for Leonard and and I know Ron Raptors
up I'm Jen point grades when we return
in a frustrated Westbrook shoot over 40%
around 40% of three-pointers you just
got to let it fly and live with the
result as 321 of the second quarter in
Game one
this LA Clippers team was outscored do
simple to simple better do simple better
we got to get those t-shirts when we go
to Chicago this summer when we go to the
Cubs game here's Kauai flying through
the air soaring and a turnover in a 6-0
run here we go defense turning them over
come on in it coming
number two rats free to go in the fourth
Durant played by he'll there we're not a
crossover
is why is so hard to stop 5 or 7/10 from
11 from the free-throw line
Gasol high-low feed and a great look
usually Tie Domi is here at the Garrett
temple is guarding Durant right now
[Music]
[Applause]
Durant turns fires count along clock
winding down turn temple tries to
contest the old Shane Battier in the
face hits him down low he's taking the
three shots and they've all been threes
as opposed to maybe putting it on Harvin
above 10 of 12 from the field 24 points
and he can extend the Raptors lead edge
Durant shot clock at 4 makes a move
Tucker defense inch by Shumpert town
count it and it's a foul on a beautiful
move by KD Wow blanketing him
defensively this goes right by him youth
I'd like to see Kobe Ryan do a detailed
on your preparation for the game it's a
thing of beauty he doesn't have that
much detail as Leonard put the left hand
claw dunk Lennon dribble penetration at
the ability to palm the basketball and
finish we're in Philadelphia sit with a
dr. J big Tom hands toran Kentucky we
saw this in Game three
but our Kevin Durant
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Leonard gets away from Paulo and throws
it - and Kawhi Leonard just blowing by
them what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content